in all of the examples that we have seen
so far we have calculated the
distribution of a random variable Y
which is defined as a function of
another random variable X what about the
case where we define a random variable Z
as a function of multiple random
variables for example as here as a
function of two random variables how can
we find the distribution of Z the
general methodology is exactly the same
we somehow calculate the CDF of the
random variable Z and then differentiate
to find its PDF let us illustrate this
methodology with a simple example so
suppose that x and y are independent
random variables and each one of them is
uniform on the unit interval so their
Joint Distribution is going to be a
uniform PDF on the unit square we are
interested in the random variable which
is defined as the ratio of Y divided by
X so we will now calculate the CDF of Z
and then differentiate it is useful to
work in terms of a diagram this is
essentially our sample space the unit
square the PDF of X is 1 on the unit
interval the PDF of y is 1 on the unit
interval because of independence the
joint PDF is the product of their
individual PDFs so the joint PDF is
equal to 1 throughout this unit square
so now let us write an expression for
the CDF of Z which by definition is the
probability that the random variable Z
which in our case is Y divided by X is
less than or equal than a certain number
little Z what is the probability of this
event
let us consider a few different cases
suppose that Z is negative what is the
probability that this ratio is negative
well since x and y are non-negative
numbers there is no way that the ratio
is going to be negative so if Z little Z
is a negative number the probability of
this event is going to be equal to 0
this is the easier case now suppose that
Z is a positive number let us draw a
line that has a slope of little Z Y over
X being less than or equal to little Z
is the same as saying that Y is less
than or equal to little Z times X this
is the line on which Y is equal to Z
times X so below that line y is going to
be less than or equal to Z times X so
the event of interest is actually this
triangle here and the probability of
this event since we're dealing with a
uniform distribution on the unit square
is just the area of this triangle now
since this line rises at slope Z this
point here this intercept is at Z and so
these sides of the triangle are 1 and Z
and so this formula here gives us the
value of the CDF for the case where
little Z is positive and the same
formula would also be true if Z also
were equal to 0 in which case we get
zero probability but is this correct for
all positive Z's well not really this
calculation was based on this picture
and in this picture this line
intercepted this side of the unit Square
and for that to happen this slope must
be less than or equal to one so this
formula is only correct in the case
where we have a slope of less than or
equal to one and now we need to deal
with the remaining case in which little
Z is strictly larger than one in this
case we get a somewhat different picture
if we draw a line with slope again
little Z because little Z is bigger than
1 it's going to intercept this side of
the rectum
now the event that y over X is less than
or equal to little Z is again the event
that the pair XY lies below this line
that has a slope of Z so all we need is
to find the area of this region one way
of finding the area of this region is to
take the area of the entire unit square
which is equal to one and subtract the
area of this triangle what is the area
of this triangle well since this line
has a slope of Z in order for it to rise
to a value of 1 X must be equal to 1
over little Z therefore this side of the
triangle is 1 over Z and therefore the
area of the triangle is 1/2 times 1 over
Z which is this expression here and so
we have found the value of the CDF for
all possible choices of little Z we can
draw the CDF
and the picture is as follows for zi-
the CDF is equal to 0 for Z between 0 &
1 the CDF Rises linearly at the slope of
1/2 and so when Z is equal to 1 the CDF
has reason to value of 1/2 and then as Z
goes to infinity this term disappears
and the CDF will converge to 1 so it
converges to 1 monotonically but in a
nonlinear fashion so we get a picture of
this type the next step the final step
is to differentiate the CDF and obtain
the PDF
in this region the CDF is constant so
it's derivative is going to be equal to
zero in this region the CDF is linear so
it's derivative is equal to this factor
of one-half so the CDF is equal to
one-half for these between 0 and 1 and
finally in this region this is the
formula for the CDF when we take the
derivative we get the expression 1 over
2 Z squared which is a function that
decreases as Z goes to infinity so it
has a shape like this one so we have
completed the solution to this problem
we found the CDF and we found the
corresponding PDF this methodology works
more generally for more complicated
functions of x and y and for more
complicated distributions for x and y of
course when the functions or the
distributions are more complicated the
calculus involved in the geometry may
require a lot more work but conceptually
the methodology is exactly the same